next question today is from Lauren
Lauren says what do you think the legal
ages should be for drinking gambling
buying cigarettes buying marijuana
driving consenting to sex and joining
the military all right I don't have so
much of a specific age I think I've
talked about how a lot of these ages are
sort of arbitrary in European cultures
where kids grow up around wine dinner
and the drinking age is 18 it seems
absolutely fine and would it be
different if it was 17 and a half or 18
and a half probably not very different
consent to sex age of consent is
different in different states can we
100% definitively determine the point at
which someone is mature enough to have
informed consent / sexual activity with
other individuals considered to be
adults I don't know that science has a
specific answer for us we can come up
with a range but I don't know that
there's anything magical about 16 17 or
18 no they're absolutely isn't but I
think you have to come up with an
arbitrary number because people do age
differently and you know you go through
that process at different points but
when you're making policy that is going
to be administered to people across the
whole population you have to come up
with a number that's what gets me to my
issue is not what is the number
necessarily as long as a reasonable
right eight years old for joining the
military I'm against 40 years old before
you can drive I'm against but they
should be consistent with each other and
this is where I've been reading Daniel
Kahneman's book Thinking Fast and Slow
and it points out how people very often
have very different reactions to if I
give you two scenarios individually for
single evaluation versus giving them to
you together very often people will come
up with different answers so if I were
to say to you on the first of the month
let's have a discussion about what the
age for buying alcohol should be we
might have a conversation and come up
with one answer if two weeks later I say
let's have a conversation about what the
age should be for joining the military
we might have come up with a number it's
simultaneously I say let's come up with
an age for a buying alcohol and join
the military joint evaluation will often
give us different answers and I think
that joint evaluation is key here does
it make sense to be able to join the
military and die for your country and
make the decision to kill other people
while fighting under the flag of your
country and not being able to buy
alcohol no that doesn't make sense to me
so that for me the big issue with these
these questions about what age should
you be legally allowed to do X Y or Z is
are they coherent and consistent with
each other and again I don't know what
the answer is I think the drinking age
maybe in the US the drinking age does
have to be 21 because of the entire
culture around drinking that encourages
binge drinking as soon as kids get a
hold of alcohol and blah blah blah we
had more of a European culture we can
easily lower the drinking age to 18
certainly for beer and wine if not hard
alcohol we could look at these
individual individually driving when I
was 16 and a half the earliest legal day
that I could take my license test my
half birthday is August second august
3rd I was taking my license test in
retrospect though was I truly mature
enough to really drive in the way that I
feel is completely well-adjusted
probably not there's probably an
argument to be made that maybe you
should be a little older before you can
get your license but are they in total
coherent it's interesting that you
brought up drinking and then driving
later on because I mean the driving
culture that we have here because the
United States is a big country yeah very
rural in some areas that allows people
to just you know potentially have a few
drinks and then take off in a car
somewhere yep versus out in Europe they
may take public transportation so I
think that's often used as an argument
as to why our drinking age here should
be hire more people drive when they've
tested it out it turns out that the the
car accident rates did decline and I
think that's why it's a very hard thing
to argue against yes um but I think that
you know if you're able to die for your
country you should also be able to go
home and have a drink and I think maybe
twenty one's too old I think 18 is fine
for most of these things some of them
even youngest is okay with me it's all
right wing ding a show it's been shown
that the mind is not nearly fully
developed an 818 yeah but it's may be
fully developed when you're 23 it right
and I going to wait until everyone's 23
before we enact
only thing is it developed enough i
guess would be the question so i don't
have a firm answer but i think the
system in total needs to be coherent and
sort of internally logical